non-minimalists
one of the
issues that i've seen come up about
minimalism
is the
that many people see it as elitism so
i read a comment on a blog the other day
that said
quote i think that one reason i've never
embraced minimalism is that there seems
to be an inherent disconnect with true
suffering that makes it difficult to
have a healthy relationship with those
that don't have the same privileges as
me
and i've also heard that
it is another form of conspicuous
consumption
a way of saying to the world look at me
look at all of the things i have refused
to buy
and i don't necessarily agree with those
viewpoints but i was just wondering
interested in what you would have to say
on those
things and if you think minimalism is a
type of
um
elitist
barley i guess it means
i guess it depends on what you mean by
minimalism
if you just mean like you the if you
mean asceticism that
is sort of a material asceticism
it that doesn't seem particularly elite
to me
um
but if it if it's someone selling
minimalism like you go to the gap and
they're selling shirts that say
minimalism on it
then yeah that doesn't make a whole lot
of sense that's not what i think of when
i think of minimalism let's just take
the word minimalism out of this because
that seems to be confusing you right now
i totally get it because there's baggage
with any of these terms we use so let's
pick a different ism let's just call it
intentionalism right
whatever you want to call it if you're
living
intentionally what does that mean it's
i'm using whatever resources i have in a
deliberate way
now when ryan and i grew up really poor
food stamps government assistance
we certainly could have benefited from
being more intentional with the few
resources we had yeah and throughout our
20s as we climbed the corporate ladder
and we
accumulated a ton of debt and got all
the trinkets of success we also would
have benefited from minimalism then
being more intentional with our
resources because we made really good
money but we spent even better money and
so we had huge amounts of debt we
weren't being intentional either time
when we were broke and poor and
impoverished
and when we were
supposedly successful or at least
ostensibly successful right
and and so
if we're talking about the intentional
use of whatever is in front of you your
time your money your energy your
attention
well then who wouldn't benefit from that
and so maybe minimalism isn't for
everyone but it's for anyone who is
questioning the status quo or at least
being intentional is for anyone who is
questioning the status quo
i'm as a bit of an outsider from
minimalism kate i'm wondering
what are your thoughts on this when you
hear
someone talking about minimalism or
simple living
i can see how it would conjure some
images of this
i think the only thing that
to me would signal
like not giving up the premise right if
the premise
if the premise of any of it is control
then then then you could do that with
with fewer belongings or with more
belongings i remember finding out that
the
average reader of
real simple magazine had like a
just a wild family household income
it was something like 180 000 or
something in the household and i was
like oh that's very simple that's
extremely simple living
real simple but um
i think what the i think the the the the
aesthetic that what i was what i was
reading in some things was just that
that beautiful spartan quality was just
another way of saying look at all the
time i have to curate everything in such
a way that it makes my life feel like
it's full of beautiful choices
and that can be quite elitist and quite
i think if the illusion is
that we can determine every aspect of
our lives with our magical choices then
yes i believe that is utterly [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
but i think if we
recognize that
most many some
of the things that are going to turn
determine our lives are the things we
don't get to choose and then we live
with
we just try to live with truth and
beauty and intentionality with the rest
then i say
make me a minimalist yeah so
tell me what what is your definition of
an elitist either of you
what what is an elitist someone who's
rich and
[Music]
and what what make what makes a rich
person an elitist i don't know what
makes a rich person at least i can tell
you what elite means to me
elite means performing above and beyond
something now we use elitist
pejoratively yeah and so i don't really
know exactly what it means and so i'm
not defending any point i just don't i
don't know
i think that word is thrown out there in
a way to almost shut down conversations
right there are a lot of words like that
they're shaming words in a way where
where we we throw out these words not to
have a discussion around the thing but
to almost shut down a discussion around
a thing
and i'm not saying that barley is doing
that here but whoever was
was you know commenting on whatever post
she was reading on on the internet
it's almost as a a way to be completely
dismissive well because you can take
anything and make it into the pageant of
that thing i'm just thinking of the
you know when the when the when the pope
who has
you know and
some of the most religious money in in
the universe will wear like slippers
right as a gesture of humility and like
that there's that in the midst of um
that any any theology
ideology set of choices can always be
like a quarter turn away from the from
the parity of it in which we can you
know perform all of our values without
necessarily having to like live with the
contradiction of them so i hear i hear
it when we have to strip down yes you're
imagining choice you're imagining the
illusion that um life is something to be
controlled and that's only something is
what i heard in that question that the
people with lots of choices can do yeah
but also we none of us get out of the
problem of having to make these really
like there's a lovely and boring word
for it it's prudential wisdom prudence
is this wonderful word that just means
the wisdom to
to see those fine distinctions and know
i think that's what you guys are talking
about yeah
so an elitist i guess could be a
minimalist
but i'm sure yeah but i don't know if
it's the other way because like i look
at well you're a jesus person i would
call jesus a minimalist was he an
elitist you know yeah it depends on what
you mean by elitist in that sense right
and that's why i asked the questions
because like what does it mean by elite
to me it's when someone says
minimalism is for elitists only or
whatever
i mean they're just shutting down the
conversation they are they're looking at
it and saying i couldn't live that way
because of my own desires and my own
actions and so i'm going to put a label
on it that is going to give me
permission to avoid this you know
minimalism i love what you talked about
you know
take minimalism out of it i mean look at
intentionalism or deliberatism or
curationism or whatever it is right i
mean when you look at it that way it's
hard to it's hard to sit here and say
like well only
minimalism is only good for rich people
i mean i've seen countless articles
where it's like minimalism doesn't work
for the poor it's like why would you why
would you exclude someone like that yeah
like well it's just it's fascinating to
me because
um
i'd have to pretend that we don't get
all these letters and emails and phone
calls from people from everywhere from
kenya to kalamazoo
who are talking about wherever they are
on the socio-economic spectrum
what they've realized is we've been
acculturated to have certain desires
that aren't our desires it's called
memetic desire right and and so there's
all of these sort of cultural desires
that are propagated by our religion by
culture by society by our peer groups by
our co-workers by wherever we are in our
city and
in in our careers and
these things are quite often
making us miserables she mentions
suffering
and
everyone is suffering the people i see
suffering the most and it's not that
it's not that one is better than the
other quite often the people i see
suffering the most
are the ones who i would look at and say
you have no reason to be miserable yeah
but
it doesn't make the suffering any less
real
there's kind of a nice little um
because i
like the problem of desire i know it's
like every every
philosophical
you know
school has this
problem of like the problem of desire
and like is it okay that we want things
and do we increase our own suffering by
wanting too much or chasing the like
creating malformed desires and then
drowning in them you know and we see
that
all the time with lovely people who just
keep trying and trying and trying and
buying and buying or and they just never
get there and wherever there is
it's not a place they live and uh
and there's a lovely like little
i just remember having this problem
after
coming out of the hospital when i was
trying to figure out like okay well
i don't know how long i'm going to live
but i know i have to like figure out
some kind of way of doing this
and obviously my way of doing this
before was my super super hustle train
and i was great at it
and now i that can't be the driver
and i found why can't it be the driver
because i could just i mean i i i would
just make
i would let that feeling
of productivity consume everything else
i think that's a big driver the desire
to be productive
that's also a memetic desire right other
people we see them
hands moving and
gtd whatever it is getting things done
and hustle hustle hustle right i made
that whole system one time and had lots
of folders yes like every day was a
folder
and if your partner talks to you like
you have to put it on a note then put
that note in the day folder and i was
like i don't feel like we have that kind
of relationship it's you know the
spreadsheets of goals all of these
things well there's nothing inherently
wrong with them
what i see is
we're creating a culture that is
obsessed with doing things that make us
miserable and that's why i asked well
why is that not sustainable for you
because the question you asked like okay
i got out of the hospital and i said
okay
now what no one yeah now what now what i
can't really can we all ask that yeah i
really hope i mean
my
drama tends to give me more like uh you
know i just get like stark choices
sometimes but i really do think we all
get this these really we all get the
problem of
now what like we've got number days
hours
resources
people to love everything about us is
narrows to a dot on the horizon and
because of that like what now and i
i had really let like that kind of like
being in fifth gear feeling
to
it helped me get out of a lot of
difficult circumstances i was like well
i was one of the only women who could
get like a job in my field i
i mean i was able to be hyper productive
at a time in which no human person
should be able to
and uh and all of that gave me a certain
amount of sense of purpose and joy
and then all the rest of it made me feel
exhausted and scared yeah and like it
was it was never gonna be enough and i
didn't even know how to to just get off
the
get get out of the paradigm
you